Donald Trump is sort of the perfect
straw man I mean everything he does
almost everything he does is so
boneheaded so ill-advised so outrageous
and ridiculous that rightly so voters
and media are paying a lot of attention
to Donald Trump but it's really
important not to let Donald Trump become
a distraction from all of the terrible
things that the republican-controlled
Congress both the House and Senate have
been doing since Donald Trump took
office and they've been doing some truly
terrible things also there have been no
partisan resolutions that have passed or
failed in Democrats as favor it's been
all Republicans and almost all of the
voting has been along party lines and
media has a bias to salaciousness and
sensationalism and that's reflected in
the fact that really boring sounding but
important legislation is being passed
very quietly by Republicans some of whom
are clearly having a field day that
nobody's paying attention to what
they're doing let's look at some of the
partisan resolutions that have been
passed starting by both houses okay
these are these are resolutions passed
already by the Republican House and
Republican Senate starting with House
Joint Resolution 38 on February 2nd
passing the House 228 to 194 also
passing the Senate 54 to 45 and what
this did was remove some common sense
Obama era regulations that prohibited
the dumping of coal mining waste into
public streams seems like an obvious
thing that we would want to prevent
Republicans have done away with it while
Donald Trump has been yelling at Jim
Acosta that he's very fake news on
February 3rd we had how House Joint
Resolution 41 which passed 235 to 187 in
the house
it passed also 52 to 47 in the Senate
and what this did was remove an SEC rule
that required oil companies to report
payments made to foreign governments
this was aimed at preventing corruption
by energy companies including the
bribing of foreign
stuff that Donald Trump said he wanted
to prevent senator ben cardin from
maryland said quote it should be lost on
no one that in less than 48 hours the
republican-controlled Senate has
confirmed the former head of ExxonMobil
to serve as our Secretary of State and
repealed a key anti-corruption rule that
ExxonMobil erroneously fought for years
February 15th House Joint Resolution 40
passes by 55 votes in the house also
passing the Senate 57 to 43 this removed
the Obama era rule which required the
Social Security Administration to report
the names of possibly mentally disabled
people to the FBI's firearm background
check system hugely controversial very
few people noticed that the House and
Senate Republicans destroyed this some
partisan resolutions have also passed
the House but not yet been voted on in
the Senate just a few examples of that
we have House Resolution 7 which passed
in the house 238 to 183 we did talk
about this one a little bit this was
effectively a bill that would prohibit
federal funding of any public or private
health insurance that covers abortion
this includes Obama care subsidies we
said before and I'll say it again it
would disproportionately impact
impoverished women women of color
Planned Parenthood says that
out-of-pocket abortions cost around
$1,500 and of course it was unnecessary
because there are a number of other laws
that already prevent federal funding of
abortions we have House Joint Resolution
37 which would remove 14 major workplace
rules for federal contractors involving
safety health wages disability civil
rights I mean who needs that stuff right
and also House Joint Resolution 36 which
would remove bureau of land management
rules reducing methane waste from oil
and grass drilling on public lands by by
environments a couple of others
including House Joint Resolution 57
which would
sinn department of education
accountability rules requiring
localities to report K through 12 data
to furthering equality and edge in
education and fighting the
discrimination of historically
marginalized students that's right it's
not just Betsy DeVos we have to worry
about and we can go on and on I mean
there there's a House Resolution 66 and
67 we have which would erase the
Department of Labor program that helps
private sector employees save for
retirement
we have House Joint Resolution 42 which
would remove restrictions on drug
testing for federal unemployment
benefits big government and don't forget
it's also been the Senate that's been
approving all of these atrocious Trump
nominees this is why Pat in the midst of
Trump we have to keep pushing on 2017
2018 the census we've got an upcoming
long-form piece an interview about
gerrymandering there's a lot to do and a
lot going on beyond just Trump this is a
big deal because Republicans are gonna
have control over both houses of
Congress at least for the next two years
and probably even after that - and while
Donald Trump's cabinet picks and some of
the media circus events he's creating is
causing a big stir we have to look into
the more things in policy where people
don't really want to get to the weeds as
much but it's just as important if not
more important the names for these bills
are so long and boring that it's hard to
even get people to stay tuned in just
after reading the name of it if I read
the full names of some of these bills
people would already start tuning out so
yes Donald Trump is serving as the
perfect straw man for the
republican-controlled House and Senate
and we're going to keep on it the way we
have been